hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm praying to
Frank we're gonna watch the trailer
today so [ __ ] excited for Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens I think
that's what it's called we prepared our
knowledge not on this movie well we were
like let's go over the first six real
fast let's go over the first six and we
just remembered how awesome Star Wars is
aha the speakers are not working okay oh
my god is this the right volume this is
the right volume I just want this to be
perfect well we're not in a theater
there's been an awakening have you felt
it
whoa cool
the dog side so back
oh what a long ass wait oh god it
totally has that JJ Abrams's touch I was
sort of reminded of what he did with
Star Trek and then watching this though
I'm like yeah sure there's some that's
our JJ Abrams touch but it [ __ ] feels
like Star Wars watch I'm gonna show you
guys just how knowledgeable we are real
fast can you believe it's been you can
add 38 years 7 the force is not strong
with you I don't want anything I say
wrong I'm gonna get someone wanting to
[ __ ] murder is I was questionable
about JJ Abrams cuz I was like I love
did you know I love JJ Abrams movies too
I even love mission impossible 3
I don't know why's that I even love like
it's like it was it no one likes it
basically with JJ Abrams I was like but
he already did Star Trek and I was
concerned if they were gonna feel like
the same movie they don't I'm like this
is Star Wars but in an updated version
what George Lucas seemed like he
couldn't really do with like episode 1 &
2 I know the smart thing is to dislike
the episode wanted to that's what I hear
to fit in with a crowd right yeah okay
right no we fit in now I know it sounds
maybe I'm gonna have a lot of people
that are hating on me but I should did
still like one into what the [ __ ] are
you doing I don't care that look so bad
all those haters they hate Jar Jar Binks
and thud I just thought it was a little
cute thing all right you brought it out
of me yeah how a webisode wanted to do
actually you know what I also like about
this one is that it looks like a good
combination between the old and the new
absolutely surprisingly I mean it's just
a teaser trailer
it doesn't seem overblown with like
crazy cities and production design of a
[ __ ] ton of stuff like it actually felt
a little bit toned down but that may be
because there going to be other trailers
coming out and the special effects are
not completely done so they wanted to do
this simplified version of it I'm not
sure that's why these episodes that we
do are speculation speculative yeah they
are not facts No
so you are definitely making your time
worth
I love the imagery of it all like this
shot of the stormtroopers I thought was
so [ __ ] cool it looks like they
improved upon a lot actually you know
like I love the original designs of Star
Wars there's definitely some CGI visual
effects but there's something about the
more authentic practical side to it
episode one two and three were like I
like them but they're all like very
heavy on CGI and [ __ ] which makes sense
because before that's true this is
causing me to think a lot it just looks
like they actually improved upon the
effects I mean okay I don't necessarily
agree with improved upon I think that
it's changed because a vision was
different it's like saying the original
Batman sucks because of the costuming
and then Chris Nolan changed it and his
is far superior whoa well it's not the
same it's not something you want to know
why it's not the same ready because
Batman was Tim Burton's and then it was
Christopher Nolan's which was totally
separate this is a sequel to Episode six
it's a little bit more difficult for me
to just go oh it's just a different
director with a different vision you
know what you actually have a point now
that I finished that whole statement I
was like wait you're like we know you're
running I like him going back to the
first ones because the ones that came
home 77 no be careful what you say
I know and the ones currently kind of
there's an homage to that absolutely
even though the ones came that came out
afterward are more technologically
advanced and many like better CGI a lot
but I I like the emergent it looks like
incredibly badass and I'm not gonna lie
first shot of a human being was not
expected to be a black guy not expected
we need him pop up he's cute I was like
I was like
oh [ __ ] he's black III got distracted
why you know it's just because of like
how often you know do you see a black
guy put up front for the Star Wars like
hey the first image we're gonna see of
Star Wars and that is no black guy
imagine being that actor though he's
gonna be famous yeah absolutely
I want to know anything how lucky and
how fortunate how big is his role in the
actual film if he's featured so
prominently ah true he's helping them
I don't know I'm exact I'm I'm kind of
excited about the storyline I have no
idea obviously what to expect I want to
clear something up I want to say that I
like the fact that it was a black I
don't want people to think I was like
didn't enjoy that I'm saying I actually
appreciate that sure some of you guys
are gonna be like hey it's not a big
deal anymore but then some people are
gonna be like no he's right that's what
comment boxes are for people comment
boxes let's watch it again red are we I
am even if I'm not plating the video I'm
still gonna watch it okay
- needed awakening is that Benedict
Cumberbatch have you felt it it's gonna
be the humanizing
I love that
[ __ ] is that I want to know who that is
wow dude so good Lenny of Falcon is like
so bad and they got the music plane over
it that happens you're like the actions
gonna look cooler like no it seems like
because that's what's that's what
[ __ ] works about JJ Abrams is he
knows how to make a movie with
characters and provide it with like
awesome entertainment do you agree I do
I do I do a great yes I was so caught up
in being questionable and concerned
rather than remembering that JJ Abrams
is actually a really good director to
seeing this footage I'm like yeah he
knew how to add a new flavor to it but
also uh you know being like what you
said honoring the previous ones yeah
that's what I'm repeating what you say
that's okay I thought I was even gonna
be a point and then I just realized
those it's okay same point I love that
we watched it you get a lot more from it
and I forgot to mention earlier the r2d2
and I was like oh you mixing over that
was r2d2 wasn't it
I don't know wait we gotta be careful on
what we say here it so is r2d2 I thought
it was just seven cool look in detail
cause he had the UM Sam same sounds and
I was like oh that's aren't you details
dammit which to say oh that's even
cooler another to see how are know who
that chick is on the bike and who's the
bad guy this is just a really good
trailer because it leaves you wanting
more mm-hmm without revealing what that
we're dealing which is what JJ Abrams is
like so good at doing with promoting his
films anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where our videos are normally
not this long oh yeah it depends you
know really we talk forever and then I
just cut it out some [ __ ] you know it's
usually what the other person saying how
you just keepin what I'm saying without
super-intelligent all the good it's like
anything slow the day Sam is going to
yeah and then cut them out and just and
brandy price as a channel - you can
check out her channel thomas steel can i
have a shout out for my youtube channel
dark new productions duke new print
don't know dark dark new productions
i've seen it before it's clever channel
I haven't but I'm sure it's really
awesome
yeah it's probably a good channel mm-hmm
I mean his last name steel like Manistee
like Man of Steel
Moustafa tall
hey real rejects I would like to have an
interview with you guys if you're
interested let me know for more info
hope to hear from you maybe maybe this
will be our interview right now I'll
answer all your questions
12 inches um I go about five times a day
it really helps me lose weight um I'm
okay with juice yeah I'd have to say Mel
Gibson I've tried it before you know
like with like four guys but it really
wasn't for me
Stacey Calais Sky East oh hey guys
kalisto hey guys it's Krystal cook I've
been following your channel for a while
now and it's inspired me to go into film
at college you don't need college can I
get a shout-out because I do comment on
most of your videos and I rather do it
now because you and the other rejects
will forget us when you reach worldwide
fame soap true what you think I'm gonna
I'm gonna hire someone to look at the
comments for me you think I'm gonna read
all the comments now I'm gonna hire
someone pay them $5 an hour $5 an hour
is below minimum wage well it's a
[ __ ] shitty job it's a lazy ass
person's job that's a [ __ ] look for
words in a comment box Jesus don't
complain about your future employment
Brandi that won't be me that will be you
thank you for commenting on all our
videos and know I won't forget you guys
I really won't I will do my best to keep
on reading the comments and Krystal cook
you are a girl going to film school now
here's what
I learned about the business if you want
to get ahead you keep having sex with
people who are in the hierarchy bone
producers bone directors do what you got
to do crystal to make it happen in this
world